فيما يتوقع ان تحل رئيسه تايوان
ضيفه على الولايات المتحده نهايه الشهر
الجاري حذر مسؤول امريكيه رفيع الصين من
التصعيد تاكد ان واشنطن لا ترى اي مبرر
لان تستخدم بكين هذه الزياره كزريعه من
اجل تكثيف اي نشاط عدواني حول مضيقه
تايوان كما اوضح المسؤول ان الاداره
الامريكيه تطالب الصين بابقاء قنوات
الاتصالات رفيعه المستوى مفتوحه بحسب ما
نقلت رويتروس وفي السياق اعتبر المسؤول
انه لا شيء جديد في زيارات ساي وانها لا
تختلف طبعا عن زيارات سابقه جرت وبالتالي
لا يجب تحميل هذه الزياره اكثر مما تحملهم
على الجهه الاخرى مشاهدينا نددت وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه بتلك الزياره مؤكده
رفضها لها تحت اي مسمى او عنوان
توترات بين بكين وواشنطن بلغت اعلى
مستوياتها منذ سنوات اما السبب في الدعم
الامريكي لتايوان ففي اغسطس 2022
اجرى الجيش الصيني مناورات عسكريه ضخمه
ردا على زياره رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
لتايوان
كما ارسلت الصين سفنا وطائرات بانتظام عبر
خط الوسط
واطلقت صواريخ فوق تايوان سقطت في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه لليابان
من جهتها تايوان ساعه الى الطلب من واشنطن
زياده دعمها العسكري لتوافق واشنطن على
بيعها اسلحه من هذا خيره لطائرات مقاتله
من طراز اف 16